une histoire pas franchement joyeuse à
présent oui c'est celle de Richard
Richard a 28 ans c'est un Guinéen arrivé
en France en Touren il y a 3 ans et
alors que son seul souhait est de
s'intégrer de travailler ici et qu'il a
même trouvé un patron couvreur la
préfecture ne lui a jamais donné
l'autorisation d'exercer pire encore le
jeune homme a reçu il y a quelques jours
une obligation de quitter le territoire
français Léa Turquie elle a rencontré
pour
nous Richard a 28 ans il est guinéen et
est arrivé en Touren en 2020 et de puis
il cherche du travail et en a même
trouvé il y a 2 ans Mathias en recherche
de main d'œuvre signe une promesse
d'embauche pour l'accueillir en tant
qu'apprenti même le contrat avec le
centre de formation de Saint-Pierre
descor est signé pourtant sans
autorisation de la préfecture la
situation reste au point mort on a des
des démarches à faire mais il y a il y a
pas d'issu le si ce ce jeune il
travaille avec moi il va passer chez
tout le monde du village c'est-à-dire
qu'il peut se promener dans le sur les
trottoirs du village et tout le monde le
connaîtra et lui dira bonjour et ça
c'est génial pour une intégration j'ai
fait les les démarches en boné du forme
et et voilà et on attend on attend le
feu vert un feu vert qui tarde à arriver
tous les dossiers sont envoyés la
préfecture a même demandé des documents
supplémentaire à la mi-septembre et
depuis unique réponse une obligation de
quitter le territoire arrivé le 6
novembre dernier ça fait 2 ans comme ça
qu'on se connaît on on se bat pour avoir
des Bones dousées pour qu'on puisse
travailler ensemble et moi je vais faire
la formation travaill partir à l'école
avoir un diplôme pour la future quoi
donc euh ça c'est c'est très très dur
pour moi mais moi le kitf là où je vais
partir dans quel pays maintenant où je
vais partir moi je vais rester en France
comment j'ai gagné ça qu'est-ce que je
sais je sais pas comment je vais devenir
pour demain aujourd'hui Richard est
bénévole au resto du cœur et à
l'association tourangel la table de
jeanne-emarie il loge en famille
d'accueil à saint-épin si la situation
n'évolue pas devra quitter le territoire
français le 6 décembre